trackmania is a racing game pure and
simple
people spend years trying to break track
records where the difference between
good players and the absolute best can
be just a few fractions of a second
now it may not be one of the biggest
esports that we cover on this channel
but it's currently reeling from
a massive scandal because it appears
that many of the best track mania
players in the world
have been cheating for a long time
[Music]
all right just before we get into this
video i just want to say that
we do cover a lot of stories like this
on this channel a lot of cheating
stories especially in donat me
so if you do enjoy these kinds of
stories make sure you subscribe to the
channel so you'll never miss a video
just like this one you give us a
subscription we'll give you great videos
like this
it's a great deal so trackmania is a
series of racing games that date all the
way back to 2003 originally
in this game it's you versus the clock
you can race solo you can race against
your best time or the best time of other
players
part of the appeal with this game is
just how simple its design is
there's no gimmicks here you push
forward and try and take the corners
as best as you can that's pretty much it
players that upload their best times to
the trackmania leaderboards
and it's here where you really start to
get a sense for how competitive
this scene is for example take the
popular a01 track
the current record for the track is
23.84
seconds there's another time there
listed as being just
0.67 seconds slower than that
and it's in the 93rd position on the
table
the point is it's insanely tight and
competitive at the top
so players upload these replays to the
leaderboards
and these replay files also contain the
exact
inputs that the player made during any
given race
every slight left every hard right
like everything in 2019 a polish
programmer called donna diego
created a script that could extract
these inputs
and play them back allowing trackmania
fans to
watch these records they were chasing
exactly as they happened
now this was great for the community but
it also meant that people could now see
any
suspicious looking replays with inputs
that didn't quite make sense
donald ego was approached by a pro who
wanted him to take a look
at the replays of another well-known pro
riolu
they told don diego they were suspicious
of some of ryolu's replays
i spoke to don diego to find out more i
won't say the name of the player that
approached me
but it's pretty well known player within
the trackmania nations forever
game so i i took the replay i fed it
into my tool and i sent
them the clip and well i was
pretty concerned the inputs
looked very strange but
at first you know it's real so i thought
you know maybe it just has some
discrepancy in in my tool or
or some bug in the game basically
here's a replay that took place on
riolu's stream you can see
him inputting left and right in a normal
amount of time
this is the kind of thing you can expect
from a legitimate run
but if you look at riola's inputs from a
faster offline stream
you can see an almost inhuman amount of
flickering going on as he taps his
controls
and in this game that's enough to raise
some serious eyebrows
this level of super fast inputs is only
really possible
if you're moving super fast or the game
is running super slow
now cheaters in track mania have been
known to slow down the game before
it's a lot easier to pull off the
precise movements it takes to break a
track record
if you have loads more time to see
what's coming next and react
dollar digo then teamed up with virtual
a popular trackmania content creator
to see whether ryolu and others had
slowed down the games to get some of
their record
runs i spoke to virtual to find out how
they set about with the
mammoth task ahead of them so the
investigation really was
is this slo-mo or is it something else
because it certainly wasn't normal
it certainly wasn't like how a human
would play track mania
so we that's sort of the angle we
approached it from can we find any other
way to replicate these
inputs that we're seeing apart from
slowing down the game speed
now they have to be careful here the
report in which they
published the results of this
investigation stated that they wanted to
take into account
other variables that might explain the
suspicious behavior they were seeing
maybe in the suspicious runs their
control was broken
maybe they were using a high sensitivity
or a specific
type of joystick with this in mind i
wanted to know
how did these investigators determine
what constitutes
suspicious behavior so suspicious
behavior basically means that
the the inputs of a replay look
fed up look or or in other term
terms they look much different than
the grand scheme of things of other
players right if you compare to
the majority of other players they look
very differently
they spent a lot of time trying to
replicate the suspicious runs with
increased controller sensitivity
different controller settings and even
copying the joystick movements
for them nothing seemed to come close to
replicating the suspicious
inputs that they were seeing however if
the players had
slowed down the game using a piece of
software like cheat engine
then the results would make a lot more
sense to them
now it's important to note here that
trackmania does actually have its own
validation system
to make sure that the replays are well
valid but all this system does is check
to see if the inputs from a player's
controller
lines up with their position on the
track as long as it doesn't break the
physics of the game
the system deems it to be a valid run
the problem is when you slow the game
down you make it
way easier for yourself but your inputs
and your position on the track
still match up when you speed it back up
to a hundred percent
meaning these replays were always given
a valid stamp
if virtual and dardigo were gonna
confirm their suspicions of these runs
being slowed down
they were gonna need a system that was
much more scientific than just saying
these inputs flicker too much they came
up with an algorithm that could put
these input flickers into measurable
terms
and they called them spikes they could
then compare the spikes per second from
a known legitimate run
to a suspicious one like one of riolus
the algorithm measures how much
how how many of this direction changes
so
from steering left to steering right
that would be one from right to left
that would be two how many of these
happen
in a certain time frame so for example
we used
for the investigation we used one second
so in one second
how how many times you change the
steering direction
the average amount of spikes per second
they saw in a normal replay was around
three with a peak of about six or seven
after analyzing
573 of ryolu's runs
they found an average spikes per second
of 11.73
considerably higher than the community
average another eyebrow razor was that
these
high spike runs never seemed to happen
on stream where people could easily see
if the game had been slowed down
upon closer inspection we found that
only runs played offline
exhibited very high spikes per second
and unnatural fast
tapping movements while his steering
movements in runs played live on stream
or on online servers
is much smoother and the steering
changes are less agile
after analyzing hundreds of replays
using donna diego's script
they published a report which argued
that seven
well-known pros including riolu had used
external software to slow down their
games
one of those players techno actually
reached out to virtual and admitted that
yes
he had slowed down his game in some of
his runs by as much as
60 percent he said it wasn't something
that he was proud of and that he did it
to try and
reclaim some of the world records that
ryolo had taken from him
other top racers then came forward and
admitted they'd done the same thing
it's hard to understate just how big of
a deal this was
these heroes of the community gods of
the track
had cheated plain and simple virtual's
video on the whole investigation
has almost hit a million views and has
reached people
far outside of the track mania community
it looks
so fake even like not looking at this i
mean obviously 20 20 hindsight
but looking how tightly he's just like
since control
is insane the pressure has mounted on
riolu to address the allegations
that were laid out in the report but
he's flat out denied them
the pair had actually been friends
before all of this and virtual had
originally
approached ryolu to address the
allegations in private but ryolu pushed
back against what he saw
as a witch-hunt what bothers me is that
you're apparently putting yourself into
the position of the self-proclaimed
trackmania police because that's in fact
what they're doing right now
and that you're seemingly lacking any
type of trust to me that's the more sad
part about it actually
just yesterday you said you weren't
gonna start witch hunts with people
they're over people but what you just
wrote seems very much like it
so this brings us right back to now the
report is out these players have been
exposed
and their records expunged from
trackmania forever
donald ego has also released the
competition patch which aims to address
many of the issues that led to this
whole scandal in the first place
it independently verifies the metadata
from all inputs
to make sure they came from a real
hardware device
and prevents players from being able to
play in slow motion
undetected players now actually need
their records to be run
with this patch to even be uploaded to
the trackmania leaderboards
so that's one happy ending for all of
this i guess but for
virtual the final chapter will only
really close when ryolu addresses the
allegations
i think it will sort of be a relief to
the community because right now a lot of
people are just
waiting for closure like we haven't
heard anything from
rio for example so it's like did he
achieve did he not cheat
people are waiting for answers i think
once this comes out it's going to be
like the
the the final piece like we can move on
after that
virtual and donadigo admit that even
though they were thorough
there's no way to know if someone
cheated with a hundred percent certainty
for example when donadigo told me about
players having
high spikes on suspicious runs i asked
him if a cheater could simply
slow down the game and then not move too
much
thereby avoiding detection it's totally
possible and
in fact we worked with some people
that know that some replays are cheated
and when we
inspected them they had a very low score
but they were cheated they were slow
modes so yes it's definitely possible
to cheated the system in a way so
basically they admit that this system
can't catch every cheater that tries to
slow down their game
surprise surprise cheaters will even try
and cheat
a cheat detection system but they
believe that just because it's not
foolproof it doesn't mean it isn't going
to help fight cheating in trackmania
for them is less about eliminating every
possible cheat
and more about making trackmania a
living hell
for any future cheaters i really hope
that you know this is a wake-up call for
the entire community
that uh we should really try to and then
strive for fair competition going
forward
so that we can just never have to deal
with something like this again
um cheating is of course an
inevitability in games
people want to get ahead in competitive
environments
but we should still try to make it
like we did now difficult enough that
people don't
uh bother hopefully and that if they
bother it's more likely that they get
caught as well
we do make a lot of these types of
stories on this channel especially with
donor
at me don't ask me what to say
i used to be insanely good at mario kart
i actually raced for england in a mario
kart wii tournament and that's a little
known fact about
yeah i mean listen it was online it was
all run by like an online forum but
hey i was i was fast enough on the on
the track to um
to do that and i think we came like
fourth or something
dude i was oh my god i think that is one
of the most successful games for me ever
i was insane at it honestly